um at the end of the day
no matter what trump says if he doesn't
have followers in the republican party
it doesn't really matter
but he does have followers matt gates
marjorie taylor green
herschel walker and others
but if nobody pays attention or takes
them seriously then it doesn't really
matter but unfortunately there are tens
of millions of people who love this i
hesitate to even call it a movement it's
sort of a perversion of a movement but
there are tens of millions of people and
here are a few of them who went to the
trump rally over the weekend
here is a woman who believes
things have been so bad under joe biden
that obviously everybody's going to vote
trump in 2024. specifically
so you know trump is going to have a lot
to do
a lot of work but see he's the one that
knows how to do it
and
people that
didn't vote for trump they're going to
do it this time because
they've been taught a hard lesson
yeah
a hard lesson so that's a very
optimistic trump supporter saying
they learned the hard way
they learned the hard way and of course
what we've learned is
trump's willing to try to steal an
election he lost in order to stay in
power ignoring all elements of democracy
and checks and balances in this country
here's just kind of a funny cringey
moment there's a guy in the audience
at the rally who wrote what he describes
as a very patriotic song
but nobody will listen to it so he
insists on giving us a few lines this
this is this is weird we're trying to
release a a patriotic song but i can't
get anyone to listen to it here
oh you guys want to hear it yeah oh
you're gonna sing it no it's a
missionary friend of mine that wrote it
but uh i i played it for a few people in
houston
and uh they said they were going to get
back with me but two people in houston
said let me think about it that's not
that's not bad that's a ringing
endorsement so it starts off life
liberty and truth worth uh fighting for
uh honor
love and and truth is worth dying for
and it uh mentions everything about the
great awakening but i can't get anyone
to listen to it
i can't imagine why i mean it's such
he's such an inspiring speaker and it's
such a such a prescient message that
sounds like a great song it's kind of
bad no one wants to listen to it well
just everybody's busy you know
everybody's doing something you know
well how do we hear it if this guy give
me a card i'll send it uh send some of
them
i will mail you a cassette tape with the
song on it i'm continuing our tour of
the trump rally another guy at the trump
rally had a suggestion for balancing the
budget so no shortage of economic ideas
presented either valley here how's it
going sir you know how they can how they
can balance the budget
how's that drill two oil wells in alaska
and let it all go to the national budget
then we won't have no worries about her
inflation neither to take care of her i
missed the dead trump back in there to
take care of all this
biden needs to retire harris needs to
retire pelosi needs to retire schumer
and all him idioms up there
it sounds like he's saying [ __ ] but i
guess he's saying retire
um
yeah okay so he has some economic ideas
which are very very interesting and then
lastly here's a guy wearing an american
flag jacket
with an fjb that's you know f joe biden
hat on
who drove
i guess to georgia from new york and
waited six hours in line now
i'm not ridiculing this
understand the level of
commitment and devotion that some of
these people have i mean i i'm the first
one to say
i don't know of anyone who would do that
to just hear joe biden speak not because
they don't support biden but because
there's not a cult like obsession with
him as an individual it's just is he
doing an okay job as president i don't
need to drive across the country to
listen to the guy i'll watch it on tv
but understand that that it's important
that they have this level of commitment
what he's uh doing over there in poland
right now he's going to be in the
refugees of ukraine he's making an idiot
of himself he hasn't been to the
southern border but he's been over to
ukraine exactly
it really is it really is
so you guys from georgia okay anyway so
then the guy goes on to say he drove
there from new york and
stood in line for six hours and
etc cetera uh we
if we misunderstand these people
they're going to win again
it's it's just the reality of the
situation
and so it needs to be taken very
seriously and we are now it's easy to
laugh and say guys it's been almost two
years since the election they're still
saying it was stolen they still call him
president trump they still say he's
really the president and we laugh and we
point but that is a level of devotion a
cult-like devotion that
fortunately doesn't exist on the left
like you know i don't really care about
politicians from a personality
standpoint it's just like are you are
you gonna do the things you promised and
are you gonna do things i agree with
that's it i'm not driving anywhere i'm
not there's no cult like interest
but this is exactly what could rocket
them back to the oval office as soon as
2024. so it should not be ignored a
dystopian
horrorific
weekend in georgia